[Music]
but we are kind of unironically
supporting caitlyn jenner
on this show um i like
caitlyn i think she's an example of true
diversity in a country that
claims to want it and does not
we do not want diversity we want
young good-looking
ethnically diverse but usually
ethnically ambiguous
people that all have the same life
experiences
views thoughts we like mediocrity
uh we do not like um greatness
and caitlyn say what you will is an
example
of greatness decathlete olympian how
many gold medals do we know oh let me
see
i mean a woman who has truly
lived many lives
and she's she's what the state of
california needs
yeah and 76 for the decathlon won the
gold medal
yes amazing she's a denizen of the
country club
she's a denizen of the she likes
diversity the way
a lot of people of her generation like
it they like seeing it on tv
they don't want it too close
um you know she doesn't really
love the homeless
she wants them gone she's a country club
uh trans person who
murdered two people in a car
and acts like it doesn't happen she's
just heading down the pch
a hundred miles an hour remembering the
good times remembering people
putting gold medals around her neck
before she was subjugated to a
tertiary role in that family of
armenians that lived in calabasas
caitlyn strutted around that house like
a nobody like a
nothing like an afterthought while
everyone else engaged in feuds and
scandals
caitlyn just kind of played it close to
the vest
very
a way to come back big
big and caitlyn
had known for a while that that caitlyn
who was known at that time as
we will say like voldemort the is the
name that cannot be mentioned
because it will be dead naming and we
will be kicked off
but caitlyn uh there was another
iteration of caitlyn
bouncing around and caitlyn knew that
that
wouldn't do she said i've always felt
like caitlyn
and but i don't want to change who i am
i don't want to ch i don't want to not
be
rich and i don't want to not be
uh you know
a person that likes law and order
and money and country clubs
she likes that and why shouldn't she
she's good at things right caitlyn does
things very well so she likes
people who also do things very well yeah
she's a bit insensitive
yes the only mexican people she's spoken
to are giving her guacamole
i understand that i understand that
maybe
she's a little culturally unhip if you
will
caitlyn's spent a little too long on the
golf course
a little too much time in calabasas
doesn't really
uh regard uh diversity as
anything else uh other than like a
quinceanera on a malibu beach that's
getting a little too
loud
but caitlyn's important this is an
important figure in america we need
more trans people that come from this
background
we don't need more trans nerds do we
do we need more tumblr trans people
i don't think so it's like we don't need
more gays
that are wearing leather and pink thongs
doing cartwheels down the street
we need more gays like me people who
look
like they work on the docks people who
look like they're a crooked cop or they
have a gambling addiction
people like me we need more of us we we
get it we get the gays some of them are
very fashionable
and uh you know white women like to keep
them in their purse and take them out
so that they can interpret them while
they get hammered in orange county we
understand that those and we know that
gays are
very talented and many of them are in
theater and
there are quite a few of them as flight
attendants telling you to put your mask
over your nose you know
clearly not a dream job but you can junk
up you can do a lot of drugs and then
[ __ ] people
in the different places you land and
then get out of there it's not the worst
job
for a gay but we just don't need more of
them in the public eye because we get it
in the same way we don't need more
tumblr trans people
we don't need more people who've lived
their entire lives
uh in a computer we don't need more
trans people that
really like anime what we need is a
country club trans [ __ ] that's not
taking any [ __ ]
we need somebody to pull up in a bentley
and get out in a christian louboutin
la bhutan and walk into a restaurant and
sit down and if she spies a tent
on her way in she's unhappy
that's what we need am i wrong
i am not wrong yes or
yes if trans people are to represent the
fullness of human experience as they
should
why in god's name wouldn't we have a
wealthy
trans olympian who's a bit out of touch
a little lucille bluth in
her she doesn't really tolerate
uh too much self-pity she doesn't like
it you can tell
that caitlyn jenner is a tough [ __ ] she
is
she doesn't really tolerate you if
you're going to she doesn't like the
whimpering
oh i don't have money oh i was just in
the middle lane on the pch
any of those things she doesn't like it
it doesn't matter because she's got
somewhere she wants to go
and it's usually a 12 000 square foot
beautiful desert home
and i'm supporting her because i
unlike everyone else care about
diversity
and it would greatly help trans people i
had a joke when i first started comedy
we need more gay people and gangs
we need more violent gay people gay
people that other people are afraid of
you know in the same way that uh trans
people we
we need strong trans people uh
insensitive trans people people
uh who have money and aren't ashamed of
it
people who are willing to tell you that
they are better than you
she's a conservative gal she
did an interview with sean hannity in
her airplane
hangar it was one of the greatest things
i've ever seen
a great spectacle of political theater
okay now miss lightfoot who we love
is not at this level yet hopefully she
will get there
but uh caitlyn is a spectacle not for
her
transition but for all the reasons that
i had mentioned it's it's a total
package
she is dare i say the total package
and what i love about caitlyn is she
speaks kind of like trump off the cuff
she has called herself a disrupter she's
a disrupter
she's going to disrupt not only the
state of california which i imagine
she'll destroy in four to six months
but i don't care it's neither here nor
there to me i want to be entertained for
my
small house in texas it's not that big
but i want to be entertained i will of
course
be watching it very closely uh i imagine
caitlyn won't do anything
too much worse than gavin news some
although she might i don't know
but i think california should have a
caitlyn jenner they had an arnold
schwarzenegger
they should have a caitlyn jenner and as
you listen to me you're kind of agreeing
with me here
she's not going to go too far to the
right because she's
trans and and and she gets it but she's
not gonna go too far to the left
because she's a multi-millionaire
olympian who's killed people
that's the different i know that she
killed them
on accident but here's what i like about
caitlyn and this is what i think a chief
executive needs
and the governor of the state is an
executive look at caitlyn jenner
listen to her talk do you think
she spends one minute
of her day thinking about the people she
killed
do you think when she's ordering i don't
know
huevos rancheros out there at the club
do you think she's sidelined even for a
minute
thinking about the two lives she ended
in malibu no
much like george h.w bush who probably
didn't think too much about his partner
when that plane went down years ago
go to the archives i think
caitlyn has shown tremendous strength in
being able to kind of just go on about
her day-to-day life
without thinking too much and who are
the people by the way that she killed do
we know
let me look it up because i know that
see if it's public i know it was an
accident when i say murderer i'm kidding
i don't think she did it intentionally
i'm just saying i don't think it keeps
her up at night which i think is
important
she's going to be making big decisions
and running a state
she can't always be guilt-ridden
stricken with feelings of despair oh
god it's the [ __ ] hello
how are you good
uh we can't unfortunately well what what
what time
what time does it become available
okay uh uh
[Music]
what's the temperature like down there
what time is it now ben it's uh 1 51 pm
uh
no sorry buddy we appreciate it thank
you
one of the cabanas became open we're on
a wait list
t
but i can we can't do it now we're in
the middle of the show
i can't just leave here and go to a
cabana
but it's the high 60s grazing the 70s we
can go in the pool though
yeah see this is what i think caitlyn
jenner thinks about
instead of the two people that she left
dead on the side of the road
do you understand and why shouldn't she
yes there are problems
but caitlyn understands that problems
aren't real if you can't see them
who did she kill ben okay so the local
sheriff's department determined she was
driving her escalade at an unsafe speed
when she rear-ended 69-year-old widow
kim ho's lexus pushing her into oncoming
traffic
hoe died after crashing head-on into the
wolf
molasses so so only only one person died
so the wolf moleski family sued jenner
over the crash and their court papers
listed extensive injuries
their two sons one was only a month old
and wolf melissa's mother elga maurer
so uh they had cervical spine wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
she killed a one month old no no no
they're
one month old was injured and also uh
it looks like the mother uh had a
cervical
spine fracture according to the lawsuit
they sound like frauds
um they sound like frauds
i i mean i i gotta be honest uh so who
only one person died it seems that one
person and she agreed to pay out
eight hundred thousand dollars to the
family oh enough
enough she can rear-end me
push me in oncoming traffic it is said
that the one-month-old was injured is he
fine now
yeah immediately was fine but wasn't
responding to stimuli at the scene of
the crash went to the hospital and was
totally fine
she almost killed a baby whatever
i you know it's it's the it's the cancer
culture i don't like
that's that's my biggest problem is the
cancer culture
i don't like the cancer culture
and to cancel her because she almost
killed a baby to me is is unconscious
and
killed a widow just one widow who's what
69
69 how much more do you got
how many gold medals did that widow win
i don't understand you people not
getting what i'm saying here
we need this woman and we need her now
it is sad i'm happy the baby's okay
had the baby died it only would have
proven my point more
do you think that would have sidelined
her campaign if she killed a one month
old
i don't think so that's what i like
about caitlyn
i think if caitlyn had killed a
one-month-old baby she still wouldn't
really
she might think about it occasionally
but caitlyn knows she knows
can we play her clip yeah i got it right
on the homeless yeah
because this is this is our next
governor
in california and i don't live here
don't [ __ ] with me irs i do not live
here
this is a clip
of our next governor or the next
governor of california
speaking about the homeless california
my friends are leaving california i
actually wrote my hangar the guy across
front of referee he was packing up his
hangar so where are you going
and he says i'm moving to sedona arizona
i can't take it
anymore i can't walk down the streets
and see the homeless
i don't want to leave okay either i
stay and fight or i get out of here
she's going to fight the homeless
this is such an important point of her
campaign
listen to the wording her friend from
across the street
probably a guidance counselor or
something public school teacher
imagine bus driver
caitlyn is speaking to uh her friend and
he's saying i can't do it anymore
i can't look at the homeless
caitlyn's response is then i don't want
to leave
i want to fight she's going to fight the
homeless
she might go start going on midnight
raids in that escalade
what if caitlyn jenner in her escalade
was just mowing over
tent cities for the betterment of
california
do you understand that driving at an
unsafe speed with reckless abandon
mowing over tent cities mowing over the
homeless
for you the citizen do you get it
don't you get it this woman is trying to
save you
she's just said she will stay in the
state and
fight the homeless for you
presumably you don't want to do it but
she will
can you play the clip i don't know if
you have it queued up i
i know that you're concerned mainly
about the pga golf
uh championship that's what you spent
most of your time on
and showing everyone your new shirt that
your wife boy what does your wife do
the week of your the month of your
birthday she gets me a present every
week leading up to my birthday
is one of those presents anal
what what now why does she do this she
treats it like hanukkah
is that hanukkah they get a present
every day for eight days
oh yeah yeah so i guess she does like a
different version of that yeah
now does she get you a big present at
the end or do you just get a present
every week no it's just kind of the same
big present every week what have you
gotten now your birthday is when
june 25th are we even in the month of
june
no she started early because she didn't
want to wait she gets too excited
now is this the first gift you've gotten
uh i've got two gifts this and then my
new travel bag i have with my initials
on it
wow and then the gifts will continue
uh until june 25th when it's your
birthday
your gift from me is your continued
employment
which is subject to constant review
constant review because
quite frankly i don't know
can you play the clip of the jenner
interview
where she speaks about the police yeah
let me find that
because this is the only time in the
interview where caitlyn lied and i have
to call her out
because i respect her she lied
she said every time she sees the cops
she pulls
next to them and says thank you for your
service
can you imagine how startled you would
be as a police officer
if caitlyn jenner just pulled up and was
like thank you for your service bars
and then kept going which she does not
do
uh you can tell she's lying here you can
tell she's being honest when she says my
friends hate looking at the homeless
that's true
but when she says um
when she says something like hey
hey man i just pull over every time i
see a cop
and i say thank you we know that's not
the case
she says thank you to maybe the security
guard uh
at her inner gated community but guess
what even
even no even that no
caitlyn speaks to very few people it's
what i like about caitlyn she has a few
friends
she speaks to and she has a lot of
employees that she barks at
but she does like you probably say that
you know everyone on the instagram is
like treat ben better i mean
what do you have this up with caitlyn
okay fox news says caitlyn jenner i'm
100 behind our police force and they
have a clip here yes
let's let's see if this is it i don't
know if it is but
we're here tonight in southern
california for our exclusive interview
with caitlyn jenner running
uh to be the next governor of the great
state of california to replace
gavin newsom let me just ask you about
law and order that we have
you watch the riots this this summer
some democrats
media people wouldn't acknowledge their
riots i have statistics
in la 465 shootings since january
1st up 67 from last year
homicides up 26 when you look at la
county
and how many decisions well
does he do any does he do any of that 13
and gavin newsom is going to release 76
000 how many hit and runs
additional inmates for good behavior 63
000 of them committed violent crimes
would you do that not
at all i think on the
releasing of the prisoners um
criminal justice reform is very
important um
and we need to do that okay we need to
rehabilitate people
in prison and bring them back into the
community safely
wow caitlin in his case i don't know how
many of these people have actually been
rehabilitated
to go back into society um
and so i am 100
behind our police force every place i go
um if i see a cop here's a lie if i'm
driving and i see a cop i'll put my hand
out the window and give him a thumbs up
um if they're sitting there i'll pull up
and say hey thank you for your service
you know this citizen appreciates what
you do um i
100 support our police forces she's
lying
um uh as far as
i would be great what a great boss very
tough
um riding um
she's like what am i using as many
forces as
i could possibly use to stop the writing
protect the citizens
and the businesses of this community
um i think that's extremely important
the national guard
whatever we need to keep peace what is
the police
the national guard the marines the green
berets
navy seals delta force
direct energy weapons how great if she
just kept going
i would use direct energy weapons sean
you know electronic pulses things like
that
you know any type of thing that we had
radiation
tear gas you know
cluster bombs anything sean
anything to stop the riots any forces
that i could
get my hands on anything
we'll do anything sean we'll never stop
throw a brick to the window of
balenciaga we'll use a direct energy
weapon
i'll i'll i'll tell you right now any
force of sean
at my disposal and i mean anything
i mean i've got friends when we go to
dinner sean they've got weapons you've
never heard of
me and you've never heard of them but
i'm talking about
some real interesting stuff you know
there's things you can do to people with
magnets
you you wouldn't
you wouldn't imagine sean
i mean the things you can do to people
with sound do you know this now sean
sound you can pulsate energy waves
through the air
that just knock people down they knock
people
right on their ass any and all
weapons at my disposal i'm talking right
now with lori lightfoot
and we're talking about
well i'm just saying we're supporting
caitlyn that's all
that's what i'm saying we're moving on
from that now but i'm saying
we're supporting caitlyn jenner
because as the the logo of bravo says
watch what happens
you know and i know jimmy kimmel should
honor jimmy kimmel's like is it
transphobic to call her and a-hole she's
disconnect it's like hey jimmy jimmy
jimmy the joke bombed it's horrible
stop she's funnier than you it's
horrible stop crying on tv
stop pretending like you have any
[ __ ] clue about how to fix the state
or that you give a [ __ ] about the
homeless you make like 25 million
dollars a year
can you stop please this is embarrassing
now you're in bed you did a show called
the man show
you talked about beer and tits you know
this is embarrassing
you're somehow a statesman now well you
and chelsea handler gonna go on a tour
and
you know this is embarrassing chelsea
handler by the way hopefully she's
better
she got the modernist shot and i went
deaf in one ear we uh we're sorry to
hear that
we hope uh chelsea gets better we want
her hearing
out of both ears so i can tell her that
she's a [ __ ]
um but uh jimmy kimmel going after uh
our next governor not r i don't live
here
there in the royal sense
we live in texas i can prove it i don't
have to like austin to enjoy where i
live in texas which is a very pretty
area it's very quiet
people have the guts to say things over
coffee like trump was too liberal
uh but i mean we're we're getting a
little sick of this act which
jimmy kimmel can you please jimmy kimmel
joke please it just bombs horribly
is it uh transphobic to call someone a
a-hole
or is it is it not transphobic because
we're not discriminating against
a-holes god christ almighty is it bad
i want to go swimming later i want to
inflict my body on other people
it's nice to stay at a nice hotel and
inflict yourself on others
it makes them understand that no matter
how much money they spend they can't
really get away from the problems go on
i got it right here yeah please listen
to this uh
tidbit of comedy this is how well
caitlyn jenner understands
the plight of everyday californians here
in l.a
kimmel then showed a clip from her fox
news interview where jenner opened up
about how her friends are quote
leaving california i actually heard my
hanger the guy across
front of redmond he was packing up his
hangers where are you going
and he says i'm moving to uh sedona
arizona i don't take it here anymore i
can't walk down the streets to see the
homeless
here was kimmel's response ah homeless
people can't walk around them can't fly
over them
you know the late night host went on to
say this
is it transphobic to call a trans person
an ignorant a-hole i mean or does
calling that trans person
an ignorant a-hole even though she
happens to be a trans person
show that we don't discriminate against
ignorant a-holes for the full late night
segment
that's great by the way i love how they
get out of there before the audience
doesn't laugh
uh what a horrible joke just the word
it's wordy and bad i mean it's bad huh
no no and the other thing is like i
don't know where does jimmy kimmel live
which is general area uh like mulholland
drive like
hollywood hill do you know yeah yeah how
do you know uh whitney told us where he
lives
right yeah and there's a lot of homeless
people up there right with him
uh matt damon's up there yeah that's my
understanding right it's just jimmy in
the homeless
singing kumbaya
because caitlyn doesn't understand the
needs of everyday californians
but jimmy kimmel does he understands the
needs
of everyday californians okay
whatever